so Connor record jobless fall here
lowest unemployment rate since 1975 the
labor market is tight by any definition
while wage is rising
I mean there's a lot of different
theories for what might be driving it
you know it's definitely a good news bad
news story today that's definitely the
good news side the bad news is obviously
inflation and falling wages but another
element of the bad news story is that
productivity again had another week
month and you know there's those other
factors involved in why wages might not
be rising but I think at the heart but
is getting productivity rising again in
the UK is is such a massive challenge
that's been going on for years and years
now yeah productivity is done tied in I
guess with the fact that I was very very
striking amazing number of jobs created
during the last few months something
like seven hundred and seventy thousand
job vacancies out there which is which
means there are a few of them one in two
you know there are fewer than two
unemployed people for every job but
these people we're at the skills to fill
these roles well you know in terms of
the skills mix what what we saw kind of
in the immediate aftermath of the
recession back in 2008 was that you know
we've heard a lot of discussion around
the quality of jobs self-employment
zero-hours contracts jobs that don't
require maybe a massive amount of skills
or you know just aren't very secure but
what we've seen in recent months has
been that the majority of the growth in
jobs has been in full-time employees so
you know the idea is that these should
be kind of better positions more secure
and hopefully a bit better paid but
there's no evidence yet of that
translating into any star of wage growth
from that point yes quite striking we
talked an awful lot over the last few
years about part-time jobs being on the
rise it's full-time jobs at the moment
why do you think that is you know as you
say it could be to do with the labor
market becoming tighter if you're an
employer trying to find people and
you're already you know you're aware of
how high the vacancy rates are in other
firms maybe only offering a full-time
position is a way to get people through
the door and what we've seen you know
similar trends with zero hours contracts
where they had risen really quickly over
the last couple of years the last six
months or so we start to see that number
tail off or even fold so I think we
could be starting to see a shift in that
direction but whether or not starts to
translate into higher wage pressures is
another question yeah there was also a
big rise during the period in the number
of EU Nationals work
in the in the in the UK I've seen it
suggested in one or two places that
employers have been trying to lock in
some of these people before article 50
was triggered and we learned divorce
proceedings were instituted obviously
there's still a huge amount of
uncertainty around what exactly is going
to happen with the immigration regime
when things might happen but it's you
know it's certainly another factor that
employers are weighing up along with you
know other things that are going on like
you know increases in the national
living wage and obviously the election
is another big question mark which
partner which you know which policies
are going to blimp implemented on what
that will mean for employers in the
future I think is another you know a
factor that will be weighing on
decisions isn't the big picture this
corner productivity much poorer here in
the UK than in countries like Germany in
France their unemployment rates getting
on for double what they are in the UK I
mean I guess the story here is that
Britain we prefer to have our are
unproductive workers in work rather than
on the dole queues as they do in France
and Germany you know there's there's
definitely some element for that and
what we've seen you know one of the
factors that has sort of dragged back
wages over the last few years has been
that we've seen more people who
previously might have been unemployed or
maybe in other country might be
unemployed entered the labour market and
obviously that's really welcome from a
living standards point of view it's
better off better having people in work
than the long-term scarring effects that
come with unemployment but it shouldn't
just be seen as a straight trade-off
that you either have one or the other
and I think going into the election it's
really key that firms as well as the
part of the parties themselves are
thinking well how do we start to improve
the skills and the quality of the jobs
in the British workforce to get to get
the best of both worlds basically all
right Conda I gotta leave it there
thanks for joining me